So Leute, der Streamtitel ist Programm, heute gibt es ONLY High IQ JavaScript.
Was High IQ ist, entscheide selbstverständlich ich.
Der Chat kann es auch nicht entscheiden, der Chat hat nicht genug Primes ab, dementsprechend fehlt dem Chat der High IQ selbst.
Das funktioniert so nicht, nur ich kann heute entscheiden, was High IQ ist.
Und eins ist sicher, keine Tests schreiben ist auch High IQ.
Also verschwendet man keine Zeit und wenn man eh perfekte Software programmiert, dann braucht man auch keine Tests, ganz einfach.
Tests sind richtig massive bloated, genauso wie Kommentare und sowas braucht auch keiner.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, Kommentare durchaus, ist ernsthaft, wirklich bloated sein können, wenn sie schwachsinnig sind.
So was weiß ich, so die Kommentare, die irgendwelche Leute in der Berufsschule schreiben, so i gleich 0, da schreiben die dann,
Setz i to 0, das braucht halt keiner.
Kein anderes Kommentar, das sieht jeder.
Tests korrekt, was da alles kaputt gehen kann, das ist genau mit Verschlüsselung.
Ach, ich habe gedacht, ich habe gerade gedacht, ich hätte das angeschaltet.
Weil ich habe gerade aus Versehen auf dem zweiten Monitor random irgendwas gedrückt und da habe ich schon gedacht, ich bin gerade auf diesen Button gekommen.
Nachdem wir Archlinux usen, Leute, müssen wir erst mal das Wichtigste des Tages machen.
Gleich müssen wir noch eine ordentliche...
Musik-Playliste anmachen, aber wir müssen das Wichtigste des Tages machen. Erst mal Package-Updates.
Erst mal Package-Updates.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Sekunde, Leute.
Das, das muss jetzt sein.
Excellent. Bis, bis, bis die Package-Updates durch sind.
Package-Updates.
Wollte gerade sagen, ein Shortcut geht nicht. Package-Updates.
Ah, siehst du hier, was wird geupdatet, zeigt her. Was wird geupdatet?
Hey, NPM, passend zu unserem JavaScript-Stelz natürlich.
Python, Daemon und Qt...
Qt Base, basiertes Qt-Sein.
Für die Weeps.
Da gibt's nix.
Das war jetzt aber wenig.
Arch, by the way.
Was da am Wochenende lief.
Okay, genug.
Das brauche ich jetzt nicht in Endlosschleife.
Wow.
Was ist das hier? Wupp, wupp, wupp in Endlosschleife.
Nicht Copy-Ul. Auch gut.
Wupp, wupp, wupp geht immer im Hintergrund.
Chart 2 Verschlüsselung.
Ich mach alles rot 26.
War doch 26, oder?
Wo wieder das gleiche rauskommt.
Oh, huge, massive questions hier.
Also, Kiewu, was gibt's denn?
Hey Max, gut erwische ich dich mal im Stream.
Ja.
Ich bin in letzter Zeit aber relativ oft on.
Aber nicht lang.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das aushält.
Da muss einem doch der Hals wehtun.
Ich habe eine Frage, bei der du mir vielleicht weiterhelfen kannst.
Ich werde Computer und Netzwerk studieren.
Moment, das heißt wirklich so?
Computer und Netzwerk?
Und frage mich im Moment, wo man danach damit arbeitet.
Gibt es Firmen, die das Internet weiterentwickeln?
Hört sich für mich nach etwas an, was nur Google und Co machen.
Also, was die machen in deinem Studiengang Computer und Netzwerk,
das weiß ich auch nicht, aber da gibt es doch sicherlich einen Plan.
Und wenn man sich den Plan mal anguckt,
dann kann man wahrscheinlich auch besser einordnen, was die darunter verstehen.
Weil Computer und Netzwerk, das kann ja alles so nichts sein.
Das ist eine Copy-Pasta?
Ne, glaube ich nicht.
Das ist nicht Copy-Pasta-like genug.
Aber es ist zumindest genug Text dafür,
dass es Copy-Pasta sein könnte.
Computer-Architecture und Security auf allen Ebenen.
Da kennst du halt, wie sowas funktioniert.
Das kannst du überall später gebrauchen.
Der Chat.
Wo sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben gestern?
Aber um das hier mal zu beantworten.
Ja, es gibt tatsächlich Firmen, die das Internet weiterentwickeln.
Große Netzwerk-Hardware-Hersteller, Ausstatter,
die entwickeln schon in gewisser Weise das Internet weiter.
Das Internet entwickelt sich permanent weiter.
Und zum Beispiel
tut sich auch protokollseitig was,
erinnert sich noch einer an die
an die falsch gepushten BGP-Routen
an die falsch gepushten BGP-Routen von irgendeinem bulgarischen Provider.
von irgendeinem bulgarischen Provider.
Wo bei der Telekom
das DSL-Kundennetz nicht mehr richtig funktioniert hat,
weil die das umgerootet haben.
Das sind so Dinger, da wird sich in Zukunft sicherlich noch einiges tun.
Da sind so Dinger, da wird sich in Zukunft sicherlich noch einiges tun.
Muss man gerade gucken,
ob sich nach den Videos von heute Morgen
Nein, YouTube hat sich immer noch nicht eingekriegt.
YouTube denkt immer noch,
dass Elrisitas Video angucken,
was auf dieser Welt existiert.
Was auf dieser Welt existiert.
Es geht gleich weiter.
Maggie's videos mit eyeliner
Und mit jedem Anklicken
denkt der YouTube Algorhythmus immer noch mehr
Ich will das gucken.
Aber anscheinend will ich das ja auch gucken,
SONS W dépend das ja auch nicht.
How to code everyday- hunchback, werk basisseitig,
programmieren als mit dokumentation schreiben verbringen und tests tests sind auch nicht programmieren
nur nur nubs die sachen verkacken braun tests
wo du landest hängt auch entscheidend davon ab wo du dich bewirbst und was es bei dir in der nähe so gibt wenn es was kleineres
ist zumal im tag in zeiten von
remote möglichkeiten sind ja die
Ist ja die auswahl größer
das hängt von dir ab danach und wenn du das studiert hast wirst ja auch bescheid wissen
und wirst dich nicht bewerben mit ich kenne mich mit computer und netzwerk aus
Hot cheesecake
Also ich kann dir sagen
unabhängig davon
was du genau studierst
du wirst auf jeden fall job finden it technisch ist so mangelware aktuell die suche also suchen alle hände ringt nach leuten
gut ob du dann da hin willst die die leute suchen das ist natürlich wieder was anderes jobs gibt
es genug
Richtig gute jobs gibt es aber auch nicht wie sand am meer also es gibt an jeder ecke den job
Ob du den allerdings haben willst ob du da bock drauf hast ist natürlich wieder was anderes
deswegen finde ich immer so witzig wenn
Irgendwelche 0815 klitschen der meinung sind sie sind hier irgendwie google 2.0 oder microsoft oder
instagram
Oder was ist was ist fang nochmal facebook amazon
apple
netflix
google
oder
Müsste das müsste das nicht nicht eigentlich mit weil mittlerweile fahren heißen weil es ist ja eigentlich bei google sondern elfer bett
Weil google hat sich ja irgendwie nicht wirklich umbenannt sondern so was oben drüber noch gegründet was ihr elfer bett heißt
Also die haben natürlich nach wie vor genug bewerber
aber
ich bin zu den 05 10
klitsche um die ecke ist halt nicht google 2.0
Stimmt facebook ist auch meter und nicht mehr facebook aber jeder sagt noch facebook
Ja das das hört sich doch schon besser an
Da hast du einen breiten überblick danach nummer als elektrotechnik und informationstechnik
nach richtung computer und netzwerke ja vielleicht entwickelst du dann doch mal irgendwann das internet neue
twitter war nur weil damit lustigerweise noch nie dabei
Was ist okay wir müssen mal kurz eine sache gucken wovon wir anfangen was ist eigentlich aus wie mochi
aus dem tv mochi fork geworden
Gibt es gibt es okay gab es auf dem offiziellen tv mochi updates 9 tv mochi updates gab es nicht aber tv mochi
forks wie sieht es aus mit unicode 15 support in tv mochi
Ich weiß ich brauche unbedingt das gänse emoji ohne das gänse emoji tut sich
Da tut sich ja gar nichts hier
Okay, ich meine ich sollte mich nicht beschweren die arbeiten alle umsonst daran aber trotzdem das ist ja hier ist ja fast nix
fast nichts erledigt
Die hälfte der sachen sind sind offen hier und der p port ist sogar noch auf
Moment es gibt wie mochi 15 gibt es mittlerweile wirklich
Es gab die mochi 15
Und da ist auch die ganz drin
nice
aber
moment
Dass das den fond gibt es jetzt nicht mehr oder das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr als fond
oder gibt es das wie mochi 15 hat man
Moment das gibt es den fond gibt es nicht mehr zum als fond datei kann das kann das sein ja das ist ja mal
massiv hängen geblieben
und und wie mochi und
mochi selbst ist wahrscheinlich auch kein open source
Jetzt ist die 15er version
Ja das natürlich das natürlich kacke das dann ist wie mochi wirklich wirklich
dead
Was gibt es für eine gute alternative
der etke ja
Oder oder gibt es das irgendwie noch die mochi
Open source im ort ja aber das muss das muss doch irgendjemanden von draus bauen
gibt es jetzt oder gibt es jetzt nicht
Wie mochi 15
Was ist es ttf
Was
Ja
Das gibt es gibt es anscheinend nicht
Ja das ist ja richtig hängen geblieben
Ja es macht auch noch so viel sinn
Dass ein fond von x jetzt wie mochi heißt
Wie kann ich
Okay also der neue fond ist kein open source anscheinend
Ich mein ganz ehrlich wenn die das nicht merchen können
Soll mir recht sein
Dann sollen sie irgendein dann könnte könnte auch irgendjemand irgendein patcher skript bereitstellen
Dann können die zwar nicht offiziell merchen aber man kann es benutzen
Ja das ist dummer da
Ja twimouchi scheint echt deadkid zu sein
Ja das ganz
Ich warte die ganze Zeit schon auf das ganz emoji
Ich möchte letztendlich nicht nur Sachen administrieren
Sondern was entwickeln
Ja dann, dann mach
Ich mein was soll ich dazu sagen
Es ist doch
Ist doch dein Ding was du machen willst
Also mach
Gutefrage.net
Was gutefrage.net
Du willst mich doch veräppeln, oder?
Die Frage.net, ach.
Ja.
Du kannst, das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Du kannst ja im Informatikstudium in jedem Bereich irgendwas machen.
Musst dir erstmal angucken, auf was du Bock hast.
Das wirst du aber wahrscheinlich nach einer Weile im Studium halbwegs rauskriegen,
ob dir Programmieren eher liegt, welche Richtung, eher Hardware-Embedded-Sachen, Web-Backends, was auch immer.
Wie würdest du kündigen, wenn dein Chef im Urlaub ist?
Ganz einfach.
Bei mir ist der im Urlaub, aber ich muss diese Woche kündigen, weil sonst nicht die Kündigung ist.
Ist egal, ob dein Chef da ist oder nicht.
Du schickst das einfach in, oder du gibst das unter Zeugen ab bei der Personalabteilung.
Habt ihr eine Personalabteilung?
Du musst nicht, du hast es eh falsch, bei deinem Chef zu kündigen.
Du musst zur Personalabteilung.
Dein Chef kann ja eh nichts machen.
Ansonsten wichtig ist, dass es zugestellt wird.
Ob du...
Was?
Der Wim...
Der...
Gründer ist gestorben.
Wirklich?
Oh, ist das geil.
Wie hieß der?
Bran...
Mo...
Mul...
Bram...
Genau, das hier.
Ist er gestorben?
Wirklich?
Ach.
Tatsächlich.
Der hat Spenden für Uganda gesammelt, glaube ich.
Ist das das Erste, was mir...
Oder war es Uganda?
Das stand in Wim...
Immer, immer, wenn man Wim aufmacht, spendet für Uganda.
Steht da drinnen.
Ja, hier.
Uganda.
Ja.
Das habe ich noch gar nicht mitbekommen.
Guck mal, so langsam sterben die ganzen Leute jetzt auch schon in der IT.
Ist ja Wahnsinn.
Da merke ich, dass ich alt werde.
Er bleibt dann sein Entwickler.
Es bleibt sein Entwickler.
Wie alt war der so?
So extrem alt kann er noch nicht gewesen sein.
Vielleicht 50?
Nee.
Der muss älter sein.
Wenn er Ende der 80er in der Amiga sich zugelegt hat, wahrscheinlich 60 oder so.
Alter?
Alt?
Meistens steht er doch immer noch, ging im Alter von sowieso von uns oder so.
Wie alt war der?
62.
Ja, okay.
An was...
An was ist er gestorben?
Hahaha.
Doppelpunkt WQ Ausrufezeichen.
Ja.
Also, ich bin ja eher für Shift-ZZ beziehungsweise Doppelpunkt X.
Okay, aber krank.
Das...
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Zetke.
Also, wo waren wir hier stehen geblieben?
Ja, gib eine Personalautorin.
Da habe ich es auch hingeschickt mit Rückschein, etc.
Du kannst es auch mit einem Zeugen abgeben.
Ja.
Und schreibe in die Kündigung rein, du willst noch eine schriftliche Bestätigung.
Das ist immer ganz praktisch.
Ich meine, es ist auch gut, wenn du den Zettel hast, aber mit Bestätigung ist es noch besser.
Aber es ist nicht guter Ton mit Zettel.
Es ist nicht gut, mit seinem Chef zu sprechen.
Doch, aber was willst du machen, wenn er gerade im Urlaub ist?
Ich meine, du kannst es ja schlecht sagen.
Also, natürlich ist es gut, aber du kannst es ja schlecht sagen.
Ich kündige jetzt nicht und keine Ahnung, muss dann noch ein halbes Jahr länger warten, nur weil mein Chef im Urlaub ist.
Bleibt ja nichts übrig.
Personalabteilung abgeben mit Zeuge und sich das Ganze auch bestätigen lassen, dann schriftlich.
Das kommt dann ein paar Tage später, aber das ist ja nicht schlimm.
Und dann kannst du ja mit deinem Chef reden, wenn der wieder da ist.
Wobei, eine Sache...
Eine Sache muss ich ja sagen...
Hat sich das nicht im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen abgezeichnet, dass dein Chef nicht sogar vielleicht schon Bescheid weiß?
Oder war das...
Wie hast du dich denn...
Warum hast du dich für was Neues entschieden?
War das jetzt super kurzfristig, so innerhalb der letzten zwei Wochen, wo der im Urlaub war?
Oder ist das eigentlich schon länger mehr oder weniger so auf dem Tisch und jetzt hast du letztendlich gesagt, jetzt reicht's?
Also, wenn das wirklich aus heiterem Himmel kommt, wird er wahrscheinlich recht überrascht sein, wenn er aus dem Urlaub kommt.
Aber das ist ja nicht wild.
Ich meine...
Was willst du machen?
Bleibt dir nichts anderes da übrig.
Und du kannst mit dem ja im Nachhinein auch reden.
Kannst ja gleich, wenn der wieder da ist, gehst bei ihm vorbei und sagst, hier, weiß nicht, ob du das schon gehört hast, aber ich bin in, keine Ahnung, drei Monaten weg.
Ist eine Beratung also wenig Kontakt mit dem Chef?
Ja, dann wäre es mir noch mehr egal.
Ich dachte jetzt, du hast irgendwie so einen besonders persönlichen Kontakt zu deinem Chef und ihr versteht euch gut.
Ansonsten, wenn du mit deinem Chef wenigstens groß zu tun hast, dann nimmst du Scheiß drauf.
Ich meine...
Dann kannst du ja zu ihm gehen, wenn er wieder da ist und sagst, hier, weiß nicht, ob du das mitgekriegt hast, aber bin ich mal lange da.
Und dann ist es gut.
Bleibt dir nichts anderes da übrig.
Also, das kann man schon machen.
Wenn du einen Zeuge dabei hast, kannst du es ohne Probleme abgeben.
Ich habe meine Kündigung auch nicht per Einschreiben hingeschickt.
Ich war in der Personalabteilung und habe noch jemanden mitgenommen, der das Ganze bestätigen konnte.
Und die haben ja auch...
Die machen da keinen Akt.
Musst du dir keine Gedanken machen.
Also...
Wenn du einen Zeuge abgibst und du schreibst dir am besten in die Kündigung auch rein, dass du hier oben schriftliche...
Du bittest hier um...
Du möchtest eine schriftliche Bestätigung.
Und dann schicken die da auch eine schriftliche Bestätigung.
Das klappt...
Also, das klappt bei den meisten.
Wenn sonst nichts klappt, aber das klappt bei den meisten.
Ja, denke ich auch.
Du kannst...
Du kannst die Eingabe der Benutzerdaten auch mit Skeleton UI machen.
Compile MLF...
Äh...
Ja, also...
Ich meine...
Benutzen wir doch schon.
Ach so, du meinst hier drin in der Form.
Ne, wir machen...
Hm...
Das werde ich so wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Ich glaube, dass...
Ich glaube, ich lasse auf eine eigene Seite redirecten und mache das dann da drin.
Mal überlegen.
So, ich muss mal kurz die Musik an...
Das nervt mich gerade ein bisschen.
Das ist jetzt das 500. Mal.
Jetzt gleich...
Mir mal ein bisschen Wupp Wupp Wupp an.
Okay, komm hier.
Wupp Wupp Wupp.
Wupp Wupp Wupp Wupp Wupp.
Wie viele Tabs?
Naja.
Sind ein paar Tabs.
Und hier habe ich noch ein paar.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo es mehr sind.
Da?
Oder da?
Ey, irgendwo muss ich ja mit meinem RAM hin.
Für mich war es länger auf dem Tisch, ob er es gecheckt hat.
Ach so, da habe ich gerade schon was zu gesagt.
Ja.
So, also.
Chat-Game.
Weiter geht's.
High Performer Crimeset Mindset heute wieder.
Package Update.
Package Updates.
Immer noch keine neuen Sachen dazugekommen.
Weil ich use ja Arch, by the way.
Wo sind wir?
Oh, guck mal.
Es ist kaputt.
Es ist, es ist broken.
Wir haben es.
Leute, wir haben.
Kann es sein, dass wir es kaputt hinterlassen haben?
NPM.
Run Dev.
Wupp Wupp Wupp Wupp Wupp.
Okay, wir haben es kaputt hinterlassen.
Das ist immer ziemlich kacke.
Ach nee, das liegt daran, weil die Sachen nicht importiert sind und so.
Ja, das brauchen wir doch eh nicht.
Ja.
Nice.
Alles klar.
Perfekt.
Excellent.
Okay.
Also.
Folgende Sachen habe ich heute.
Ach.
Das habe ich ja blöd.
Guck mal.
Das kann man da oben gar nicht anklicken.
Das ist ja dumm.
Das muss, das muss ich auch noch fixen.
Da klickt man so ganz instinktiv drauf, um wieder auf die Startseite zu kommen.
Das muss schon ordentlich gemacht werden.
Gehen wir mal in die Layouts-Datei.
Gucken wir mal, wo das hier definiert ist.
Fiat Champs.
Machen wir da einfach mal einen Link drum herum.
Ja.
Wir machen einen Link drum herum.
Und auf die Startseite.
Ah.
Nice.
Kunst.
Okay.
Und das, das, das ist auch noch nicht gelinkt?
Dann brauchen wir jetzt noch einen Button.
Von unserer Startseite.
Nee.
In den Layouts brauchen wir einen Button.
Wo habe ich, wo habe ich diesen Button?
Layouts oder?
Hier.
Hier ist der Button.
Okay.
Äh.
Button.
Ja.
Gibt auch keinen Button, sondern gibt einen Link.
Und das geht auf Create.
Ja.
Nice.
Kann ich hier navigaten.
Perfekt.
Moin Max.
Erste Woche der Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung Ausbildung vorbei.
Macht richtig Bock.
Wir machen aber leider hauptsächlich PHP.
Chatge.
Pregel für Nudelwasser.
Alle eine Runde Pregel.
Damit er das übersteht.
Aber eins, einen Vorteil hast du.
Du kannst damit übelst Kohle machen.
Du kannst damit übelst.
Später kannst du, wenn du dich damit auskennst, kannst du übelst Kohle machen.
Habe ich PHP gesagt?
Äh.
SAP.
Ich, ich meinte auch SAP.
Wenn ich PHP gesagt habe, dann bin ich, bin ich verwirrt.
Ja.
Aber du brauchst, du brauchst für SAP.
Noch, nochmal.
Also wirklich Pregel.
Weil.
Da hätte ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf.
Du willst Full Stack machen.
Ja.
Obwohl vi ich gesagt habe.
Du willst Full Stack machen.
Weiß ich nicht, ob man mit SAP Full Stack machen kann.
Ja doch.
Du kannst bestimmt SAP im Frontend und SAP im Backend machen.
Ob man das haben will.
Wie viel verbraucht der Chrome an Ram?
Tatsächlich gar nicht so viel, weil Chrome ziemlich High IQ ist.
Guck mal, kaum was verbraucht.
Weil Chrome ziemlich High IQ ist.
Und.
ja.
Guck mal, ich hab eine fette VM noch laufen.
Ich hab nur 26 GB RAM in use.
Und das ist noch.
Alles.
belegt im voraus gecasht und so also insofern die meisten tabs machen bett
gehe ja tatsächlich aber eben muss ich mit dem ram ja hin jemand am anfang mit
sap arbeiten kann ist doch ganz einfach wenn man in einem ausbildungsbetrieb ist
der hauptsächlich sap macht macht man in der ausbildung natürlich auch sap
es ist ja nicht so als könnte man sich das groß aussuchen wenn du in einem
team oder eine abteilung oder vielleicht sogar ganze betrieb sap machen kannst
du nicht sagen ich mache jetzt keine sap ich bin zwar ich bin zwar zu wie bei
euch aber interessiert mich macht keine sap meine kannst du schon machen ob du
dann eine gute ausbildung hast wieder was anderes aber ist ganz großer
panes champion wie schaut das eigentlich aus muss man da immer wieder mal
irgendwelche beispiel angucken weil ich das weil ich das immer verdrängen die in
grundzügen ähnlichkeiten zu kobol aufweist oh ja das klingt ja richtig
gut
abab haben die ein beispiel okay das sieht wirklich reudig aus einer warum
ist das eigentlich aber warum haben wir das nicht mal durch irgendwas halbwegs
modernes ersetzt wahrscheinlich weil sie damit schulungen und viel geld verdienen
oder oder es ist einfach zu tief integriert in allem dass du das nicht
aus wobei du müsstest das ja nicht austauschen könnte es ja etwas neues
parallel anbieten das sind wirklich sehr gute beispiele da sind wirklich gute
nicht wie eine richtige scheiß sprache aus gebe ich euch recht chat ab ab
example was haben wir da sonst noch schönes ab ab examples moment multiline
commons macht man mit einem und das hat so das ist so eine mischung wisst ihr
wie das aussieht das sieht aus wie eine mischung aus also
zähler ist ja der meinung es hat nichts mit visual basic und basic zu tun aber
ich finde ein bisschen schon das ist so eine mischung aus sql und basic so sieht
das aus glücklicherweise brauchst du nicht wie bei kobold irgendwelche
zeilennummern vorne der end ist und so dass es eindeutig so ein bisschen ein
bisschen rutsche basic ja das ist so eine mischung sql und basic ihr like und
sowas klingt eher nach sql aber und die stehen glaube ich auf alles groß
geschrieben
aber trotzdem ich meine hey wenn die einem da das geld für in popo schieben
dann kann man sicherlich auch kobold nicht kobold aber programmieren spielen
tabs und space ist eine rolle ich gehe mal nicht davon aus
das ist einfach nur gut eingerückt oder oder oder muss müssen hier spaces sein
wahrscheinlich nicht das ist einfach nur zur besseren lesbarkeit eingerückt gibt
es gibt es moment ist müssen was gucken
vscode abbap
gibt ist da eine extension doktor war was da war was aber ist ja sehr beliebt ist
Nikki
ob es dafür gescheitere autocomplete tempted eigentlich sind solche sprachen
recht easy auto zu completen wenn sich jemand die mühe gemacht hat übrigens
interests gratuit forums eintrag sehe garmin hat das hinbekommen sich nicht immer so served
Meine Fitness-Uhr updatet wieder.
Hier, da war ja das
Geflame, das Geflame war ja groß.
Aber sie haben es tatsächlich
geschafft. Ich kann, ups.
Ich kann meine Fitness-Uhr wieder updaten.
Ja, dann, wenn du,
wenn du nicht auf ABAP stehst, kannst du ja
vielleicht in deiner Ausbildung auch nochmal bei anderen
Teams reingucken.
Keck Weight Business, das finde ich gut.
Das wird hinzugefügt.
Leute, Keck Weight Business.
Das ist nice, das gefällt mir.
Das gefällt mir.
Der Chainlaw ist immer auf dem aktuellen Stand, was das
Emote-Game angeht.
Morgen wieder fett Keck Weight Business.
Ne, ich nicht.
Morgen, morgen ist noch
Freige. Ne, das nicht.
Wir müssen, wir müssen, wir müssen
nicht jedes, nicht jedes Keck-Emote
reinmachen.
Wir haben ja schon doch recht
viele Keck-Emotes.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht hier.
Keck,
Keck-Brows.
Ich glaube, das wurde gelöscht.
Das ist normal.
So die ersten 40 Minuten passiert meistens
nicht viel. Ich denke mal,
die meisten von euch müssen
morgen Keck-Business machen, oder?
Oder gibt es noch irgendwelche
Montags-Frei-Enjoyer hier im Chat?
Jemand morgen
frei?
Und nicht Urlaub haben? Und wobei Urlaub
auch. Irgendjemand morgen, morgen nicht,
nicht Business stellt?
Morgen
Karriere-Crind.
Erster Tag nach Urlaub. Oh, nee.
Das suckt.
Das ist immer richtig kacke, bis man da wieder
reingekommen ist.
Du würdest eher den Freitag bei einer
Viertagewoche nehmen. Warum das denn?
Freitag ist doch super entspannter Tag.
Warum willst du Freitag, ups, warum willst du
Freitag nehmen?
Montag ist deutlich, ist taktisch deutlich geschickter.
Montag sind die Leute alle super motiviert
und viele nervigen Sachen passieren montags.
Viele nervigen Sachen,
passieren montags. Deswegen ist es sehr sinnvoll,
montags frei zu nehmen und Freitag eher
noch eine Runde abzuchillen
mit den anderen Leuten, weil die am Freitag
auch alle keinen Bock mehr haben, was zu machen.
Nein, wir haben jetzt genug
Emotes, Chat. Reicht für heute.
Quick-Muffs.
Genug, genug Emotes.
Dienstag bis Freitag ist das Beste.
Das sehe ich auch so. Wilder Igel blickt durch.
So sieht's aus.
So.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Da, also, Ziel ist folgendes.
Ich sag das jetzt mal für heute.
Ziel ist folgendes.
Ich möchte, wenn ich hier auf adden klicke,
ein Formular bekommen,
wo ich meinen Account eintragen kann.
Und, also, ich will so eine,
ich will so eine Art Assistent
haben. Da habe ich nämlich gesehen,
dass Skeleton UI tatsächlich
sowas eingebaut hat.
Nennt sich dort
Steppers.
Da kann man sowas hier machen, guckt.
Kann man so einen Assistent bauen.
Was ganz praktisch ist, für mich,
weil, ich brauche
ja eh zwei Steps. Ich brauche
Username, Passwort, Eingabe. Eingabe
vom Hersteller. Dann muss ich gucken,
ob das Login geht. Und erst, wenn das Login
geht, dann will ich den nächsten Step
haben. Nächster Step ist dann sowas wie
die Eingabe vom Abfrageintervall und sowas.
Also, wir brauchen quasi so einen 2-Step-
Wizard.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Was machen wir? Zeige ich dir.
Das zeige ich dir. Und zwar, wir bauen
ein Webinterface für dieses Home Assistant
Addon hier. Wobei es kein Home Assistant Addon ist.
Es kann man ja auch Standalone verwenden.
Das habe ich gebaut. Da kann
man für Fiat Auto, also für Fiat,
für Jeep, für Ram,
für Dodge und für Alfa Romeo
Elektroautos, Informationen von
einer nicht so ganz offiziellen
API abfragen. Also,
wir fragen das schon von der offiziellen API ab, aber
die ist nicht dafür gedacht, dass man die benutzt.
So. Und nachdem ich immer
mehr Leute danach gefragt habe, ob man das nicht auch
gescheit Standalone benutzen könnte,
also sprich, die Daten an
irgendeinen MQTT-Server schicken nicht zwangsläufig
für Home Assistant,
und nachdem das Home Assistant
interne Konfigurations
Overview-Ding
ein bisschen zu minimalistisch
ist, zum Beispiel um mehrere Accounts zu adden,
mache ich ein eigenes Webinterface
dafür, wo man das konfigurieren
kann. Ist Ram nicht Dodge?
Anscheinend nicht. Guck.
Connect Ram Trucks,
Connect Dodge sind unterschiedliche
unterschiedliche
Dinger. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber
anscheinend, anscheinend sind das
nicht die gleichen
Leben.
Richtig. Nach wie vielen
Jahren bist du eigentlich auf die 4-Tage-Woche
umgestiegen und hat
dein Arbeitgeber das sofort akzeptiert und sich
erst quergestellt? Dazu habe ich schon
ein paar Videos gemacht.
Da musst du mal auf YouTube gucken,
wenn du es ganz ausführlich wissen willst.
Es ist letztens auch ganz
gar nicht so lange her.
Ich habe über meine Teilzeit-
Journey schon ein bisschen was
erzählt. Aber um es kurz zu machen.
Wie lange hast du vorher gearbeitet?
Ich würde sagen 5 oder 6 Jahre
habe ich gearbeitet.
Ich zähle mal Ausbildung mit.
Ich zähle mal die Ausbildung mit.
Und
ja, also ich
habe das nicht sofort,
das wurde nicht sofort akzeptiert.
Und meine damalige Arbeit
hat gesagt, gibt es nicht,
wollen wir nicht.
Und dann musste ich damals zum Betriebsrat
und dann ging es.
Aber da musst du mal auf YouTube gucken.
Da habe ich 1, 2 richtig ausführliche Videos zu gemacht.
Ja.
Mal kurz gucken hier, Teilzeit.
Da habe ich das,
ich habe es bestimmt da in Kurzform erzählt
und da etwas länger erzählt.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max.
Karrierehemmend oder wie auch immer angesehen.
Nicht ganz so viel weniger.
Meinem Chef damals.
Das war jemand, der hat so eine gewisse
Erziehungsabsicht noch gehabt.
Jaja, hier erzähle ich das.
Das kannst du dir in Ruhe angucken.
Dann weißt du Bescheid danach.
Chandler, was ist mit dir heute schon wieder los?
Rein in die 4-Tage-Woche.
Beste.
Equigel kann ich dazu nur sagen.
Wie bist
du dazu gekommen?
Warum hast du
dich dafür entschieden?
Gut. Dann.
Würde ich sagen, wir fangen jetzt mal an.
High-Performer-Mindset.
42 Minuten, bis es richtig losgeht.
Okay, let's go. Wir bauen eine Form.
So.
Wie fangen wir denn am besten an?
Wie baut man denn jetzt hier
eine schöne Form?
Ist jetzt nicht so, als bin ich
der tolle CSS-Kenner.
Also.
So.
Eine Card brauchen wir schon mal nicht.
Backend ersetzen.
Warum soll ich das Backend ersetzen?
So. Ich kopiere mir jetzt erst mal
dieses Beispiel hier. Der Stepper.
Card full.
Ja. Lassen wir
das mal da. Würde ich sagen.
Card.
Das können wir so lassen. Das schmeißen
wir weg. Und pasten jetzt.
Oh. Jetzt ist es kaputt. Warum?
Ah. Weil es nicht importiert wird.
Warum?
Wer kennt sich mit dem
Svelte Addon aus? Warum gibt es jetzt hier keine
Möglichkeit
zu sagen. Import.
Normalerweise in Visual Studio
drücke ich jetzt. Oder in Rider drücke ich jetzt
Alt Enter.
Und dann kriege ich sowas zum Importieren. Was witzig ist,
weil wenn ich jetzt einfach so sage. Stepper.
Dann fügt das ein. Aber nicht
wenn es schon drin Copy-Pasted ist.
Also was
auch immer da kaputt ist.
Ruby.
Hast du das Daily Scrum verpasst?
Ist heute ausgefallen.
Firma hat das neu eingeführt. Ich mache derzeit
mein Informatik-Fan-Studium. Und deswegen
ach so. Ah ok. Du hast tatsächlich
noch richtig Ambitionen. Hier sehe ich schon.
Ich kann doch eigentlich durch die Stunden
reduzieren und nebenbei noch einen anderen Job machen.
Oder spricht vom Gesetzgeber was dagegen?
Nö. Kannst du machen.
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an, wenn du
quasi direkte Konkurrenz oder
so machst für deinen Arbeitgeber.
Da gibt es sicherlich Probleme. Aber
sagen wir mal, wenn du bei einer
Versicherung arbeitest und
privat streamst auf
Twitch und YouTube-Videos machst. Das
beißt sich ja überhaupt nicht.
Gaming-YouTube-Videos und sowas.
Ey, du musst nicht sagen, wo
du arbeitest. Du musst sagen, dass
du, du musst sagen, dass du
einen Nebenjob hast quasi. Das musst du
anmelden. Aber die können da auch gar nichts
dagegen sagen in dem Sinne. Die können
das eigentlich einfach nur abnicken.
Es sei denn, es
gibt wirklich eines dieser wenigen Gründe.
Diese wenigen
Gründe, warum sie was dagegen sagen
können. Die können labern.
So viel, wie sie
wollen. Da gibt es ja relativ,
enge rechtliche Rahmen,
was du machen darfst und was
nicht. Nur weil denen da irgendwas
vorschwebt, heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass
sie das dann auch wirklich
versuchen irgendwie durchzusetzen.
Okay, also wir bauen jetzt.
Okay, wir müssen, ich glaube, wir müssen mal
die Breite etwas
beschränken.
Machen wir mal hier. Breite darf
96 sein. Okay, perfekt.
Next, next,
complete. Okay, sehr schön.
Also, wir bauen jetzt eine Form.
Das heißt, Header.
Ich geb dir Header, Alter.
So, das heißt sowas wie Add Account.
Oh, sieht schon mal
gut aus. Fertig.
Completed. Finished.
Die sollen sich mal nicht zu sehr anstellen, weil
vielleicht ist er sonst nicht mal lange da, wenn sie ihm auf den
Sack gehen. OBS Chat
Overlay hat kein 7TV.
Was ist das? Warum?
Doch, das hat bestimmt 7TV,
aber ich vermute
mal, dass das nicht
probiert. Probiert nochmal.
Ne?
Wie? Kein Keck Browse. Was ist das denn?
Das ist ja
Keck Wait, Alter.
Da muss ich mal gucken, dass ich
ein anderes Chat Overlay verwende.
Das ist ja nix.
Ich mein, Leute,
können wir nicht einfach selbst ein Chat
Overlay machen? Was ist denn, wenn
ich diesen Chat hier nehme? Moment, das testen
wir jetzt mal kurz. So.
Achtung hier.
Add.
Window Capture
Nicht YouTube.
Twitch Chat, jawohl.
Aber ich glaube,
das skaliert nicht richtig, oder?
Das sieht dann einfach Kacke aus, wenn es so klein ist.
Ja, das sieht scheiße aus.
Naja.
So schlecht
sieht es gar nicht aus.
Aber die Uhrzeit müsste weg, ja?
Wir testen das mal kurz.
Ich mach den Chat weg
und das Ganze kommt natürlich...
Ah, aber der...OPS.
der Zeilenumbruch stimmt jetzt nicht.
Guckt mal.
Daran liegt das.
Okay, das ist natürlich doof.
Da muss ich mal gucken, wie wir
das auf die Reihe kriegen. Ich meine,
ich könnte auch einfach
das Fenster resizen.
Irgendwie so. Aber so, dass
die normalen Sachen da drauf passen.
So. Window Capture.
Warte, ich bin verwirrt.
Window Capture?
Ah, die Anzeige. Ich blick nicht mehr
durch. Wo ist der Chat?
Ja. Ne, das ist der Chat.
Window Cap.